un procès pour l'histoire et les regards
portés sur cet homme derek chauvine
impassible l'ex officier de police
accusés de la mort de georges floyd
capter le plus souvent par les caméras
en train de prendre des notes
après deux semaines passées à former un
jury le plus impartiale possible le
tribunal de minneapolis se penche enfin
sur l' affaire proprement dite dans la
salle d'audience l'heure est déjà aux
déclarations choc après la prestation de
serment des jurés le procureur prend la
parole pour blâmer derek chauvine et
appelé à sa condamnation
mais vous apprendrez que le 25 mètres
2020 monsieur derek chauvine la trahit
son insigne mais ce charme monsieur
chauvine bénéficie de la présomption
d'innocence
il est présumé innocent jusqu'à preuve
du contraire t nous prévoyons de vous
prouver au delà de tout doute
raisonnable que le 25 mai 2020 monsieur
chauvine était tout sauf innocent toile
étoiles au cours de cette déclaration
l'accusation a diffusé les images de
l'arrestation de georges floyd qui a été
fatal à l'afro américain de 46 ans le 25
mai dernier
des images qui avait provoqué la colère
de nombreux américains et secoué les
états unis ainsi qu'une partie du monde
au cours des mois qui ont suivi du côté
de la défense on en jouant les jurés de
ne pas politiser la faire nous ce
dossier porte sur les preuves qui vont
être présentés au cours de ce procès et
je suis d'accord avec le procureur
ce n'est rien de plus que cela il n'y a
pas de cause politique ou sociale dans
la salle d'audience des squares pas de
causes politiques dans la salle
d'audience mais des déclarations déjà
frappante à l'image de celle de donald
williams témoins de la scène de
l'incident est décrit comme pratiquant
des arts martiaux
lorsque je suis arrivé sur les lieux
monsieur flosse exprimé sa peine sa
douleur et la détresse qu'il éprouvait
plus le genou bloqué sur son cou et plus
les mouvements d'arts martiaux destinée
à couper le flux d'air se poursuivaient
plus vous voyez fleuve s'éteindre
s'éteint lentement est comme un poisson
dans un sac
vous voyez ses yeux pas lire lentement
et roulait lentement vers l'arrière de
sa tête et donc c'est ce que j'ai vu
c'est ce que j'ai entendu tension
palpable à l'intérieur et émotion à
l'extérieur devant le palais de justice
à quelques minutes du début de
l'audience à 8h46 exactement les proches
de georges floyd ont mis un genou à
terre durant huit minutes et 46 secondes
en hommage au défunt
pour eux ce procès n'est pas uniquement
celui de derek chauvine chauvine et dans
la salle d'audience mais c'est le procès
de l'amérique l'amérique est en procès
pour voir si nous sommes arrivés au
point où nous pouvons tenir la police
pour responsable si elle un frein alors
ils veulent que nous fassions confiance
au système
et bien c'est votre chance de nous
montrer que nous pouvons vous faire
confiance mais quel choix et des
dizaines de manifestants blacklight
matters ont également marché aux
alentours du tribunal
the world is watching le monde est en
train de regarder pouvait-on lire sur
une grande banderole
ces audiences promet d'être suivie aux
états unis pendant encore quatre
semaines et notamment du côté de la
maison blanche lundi
joe biden via sa porte parole a rappelé
que la lutte contre les injustices
raciales était l'une des priorités de sa
présidence